fait la majeure partie de l'état
californien sera placée sous un
couvre-feu nocturne pendant au moins un
mois c'est à partir de ce soir que ça se
passe on en parle avec eux laurent
hecquet mis les résidents de la
communauté de tyson cox cet honneur de
malibu bonjour laurent bonjour je leur
ai dit nous couvre feu imposé à partir
de ce soir c'est vraiment un couvre feu
de nuit on parle de 22h à 5h le matin
pendant un mois d'abord comment ça a été
accueillie auprès des california et
cette mesure mais pour le moment je
pense a été très bien accueilli parce
que on s'attendait peut-être un petit
peu plus qu'un couvre-feu avec
l'augmentation des cas ce qui risque
d'arriver avec peut-être un peu plus de
mesures restrictives au niveau du
confinement je ne suis pas après après
la thanksgiving qui est la semaine
prochaine donc c'est globalement ça
s'est bien accueillis pour le moment
alors qu est-ce qu on est qu'est-ce qui
est impliquée dans cette dans ce couvre
feu c'est quand on peut pas se déplacer
d'une région à l'autre
en fait tu sais ça il faut à moins
d'avoir un métier essentiel un service
essentiel docteur un travail à l'hôpital
où travailler pour reprendre service
essentiel donc on a en fait on doit
rester chez nous entre 22h et puis 5
heures du matin et cela s'accompagne
parce qu'on est dans le dernier tiers
avant avant le confinement que nous
avions eu au moins de 2 de mars avril
donc il ya des restrictions qui ont été
rajoutés par exemple les lieux de culte
comme les églises maintenant tout va se
faire à l'extérieur pareil pour les les
les jim si les gens d'aller s'entraîner
il faut que ce soit exclusivement à
l'extérieur les restaurants viennent de
refermer en fait l'intérieur des salles
où déjà il était je pense à 25 %
d'occupation maximal
donc il faut les restaurants ne peuvent
servir qu'à l'extérieur et à tous les
magasins maintenant et tu vends les kids
épicerie etc ne peuvent fonctionner
qu'avec 25 % des de la clientèle à
l'intérieur donc on ne refaire la queue
à l'extérieur
et puis et puis en fait attendre contre
tous
au début du mois on observe vraiment
chez vous une hausse rapide des codes
coville 19
est-ce que les gens prennent la
situation au sérieux mais c'est assez
difficile et californie on a eu en plus
un automne très chaud dernièrement donc
les gens sont repartis un petit peu à
sortir il ya eu aussi ce qu'il faut
savoir le la fête du travail et de la
fête du travail donc mois de septembre
on a eu des différentes week-end férié
donc hélas hélas thanksgiving donc les
gens se sont habitués se pense un petit
peu et puis et puis comme tout est quand
même assez réouvert je suppose que ya
pas mal de personnes qui font un petit
peu moins attention à se protéger puis
surtout à protéger les autres donc d'où
cette restriction qui pour le moment
tout bas touche essentiellement les gens
qui avaient repris à sortir le soir à
célébrer et cetera a passé un petit peu
plus de deux ans à l'extérieur dans les
restaurants après 22h nom commun vous
qualifierez les communs qualifier l'état
d'esprit des californiens selon vous
c'est ainsi ils sont un petit peu
résignés bon le fait que politiquement
je pense que les il n'y a pas eu de
restrictions trop trop importante parce
que le thanksgiving américain vraiment
le moment le plus fait la plus la plus
futée même devant noël
donc ils ont découragé les gens à se
réunir en fait mais ils n'ont pas
interdit les voyages
parce que je pense ça serait un peu trop
impopulaire et vous savez c'est même si
la californie est quand même un
démocrate avec une une propension à
pouvoir à vouloir se protéger un petit
peu plus il ya quand même des endroits
comme orange county au sud de los
angeles qui sont tus un peu plus
républicain où le port du masque est un
peu plus difficile à faire accepter donc
c'est difficile ça reste les états unis
avec avec leurs excès et les jambes pour
le moment en prennent ça d'une manière
adéquate et je disais tout à l'heure
c'est presque la majeure partie de la
guerre en face à la majeure partie de la
californie qui est touché par ce couvre
feu mais il ya quand même des secteurs
qui sont pas touchés je pensais à san
francisco y'a pas
y'a pas de couvrir tant que tel il ne
renonçait pas c'est essentiellement au
sud de san francisco tout le sud de la
californie qui est touché par une
augmentation des cas ces ces derniers
jours qu'ils augmentent tous les jours
tous les jours donc pour éviter
d'arriver à la saturation des hôpitaux
c'est la dernière étape on nous a
avertis que c'était la dernière étape
avant des étapes plus beaucoup plus
restrictive
alors un couvre-feu qui devrait durer un
mois c'est ce qu'ont annoncé pour le
moment ce que vous avez espoir que les
autorités arrivent à me lâcher un peu
les mesures pour le temps des fêtes
c'est pas parce qu'hier ils ont annoncé
que c'était 20 au 21 décembre mais que
cela pouvait être étendue je pense que
ce qui va être très décisif ça va être
de voir les chiffres de semaine après
cinq ans qui viennent et pour la
première fois le 5 divine américains
arrivent moyenne de moins de 30 jours
avant noël donc je pense qu'on aura la
surprise vraiment deux semaines avant
noël de voir quelle quel impact le
thanksgiving aurait eu sur sur la
propagation ou pas du virus est ce que
les gens respectés ou pas et puis ça ça
va vraiment dicter ce que ce peut être
le temps des fêtes et parlant du think
the game on a l'habitude de voir à
travers le monde les images de
congestion routière à los angeles les
gens qui partent sur les autoroutes à
plusieurs voies pour aller voir leur
famille ce genre de scénario vous pensez
qu'on verra pas cette année où les gens
vont me propose respecter des mesures si
c'est difficile difficile à prévoir ils
font beaucoup de campagnes en ce moment
dissuadant les gens de leur demandant de
rester à la maison mais les le sentiment
de liberté qui est qui et qui est
imprimé au plus profond des américains
c'est difficile pour eux de trouver la
panne ans à la liberté personnelle et
plus obligation sociale et on va suivre
ça bien sûr cette situation en espérant
qu'on lesquels fournier n'ont réussi à
casser cette deuxième vague et laurent
eyquem merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui vous en prie merci de
faire